[Music]
you're close closer than we've ever been
contract agent or lioness lionesser
we locate the wives and Daughters of
these high value targets
I told you I was coming I mean place an
operative close to them and we kill the
target
if we play this right it is over before
it's begun there's really no means to
abort they'll get her killed and expose
the entire program our asset is embedded
we don't have the ability to call her
off
so we're just going to pretend that a
CIA quick reaction force did not execute
a kill mission in front of CBS News
walk us through your decision to call
the Drone strike he was dead either way
you need to remember what you're
fighting for